[Music]
so um i'm
jeff magnusson i i head up the um data
platform architecture group at netflix
um
and so the the way that you can think of
our
our team at netflix is um you know we
kind of sit on top of the hadoop and big
data
sorry
on top of the hadoop and big data
infrastructure
and and design tools and services that
make that infrastructure is easy to use
and
as efficient to use as possible
and so lipstick is one of those tools
that we wrote
i'm going to talk a little bit more
about you know the
netflix data architecture in general
tonight as well
and i've been told that this uh meetup
is pretty uh interactive so you know
please interrupt with questions i love
questions um
uh and you know we'll we'll see where
that gets us so
um
i think one of the coolest things about
lipstick is the logo and so
feature that right there
actually drawn by the um
creative lead for
netflix kids so i can't take too much
credit for it but um
i appreciate it
um so you know i i kind of just went
over this but the the motivation for for
our team is to make our big data is
accessible and easy to use and
efficiency to use is is possible for you
know everybody across the organization
um
and
you know when we think about everybody
it doesn't just include engineers and it
doesn't just include analysts
and really you know the the employees at
netflix usually fall somewhere within a
spectrum of analysts to engineer
um and so you know those kinds of people
have um
two very different wants and so you know
you think about people who are analysts
they don't they don't really care about
um the technology underneath the data or
um how how everything runs they really
just want um you know an easy um
interface into querying it and finding
out you know what what they want to find
out um and they want you know that to
run fast and without you know any kind
of technical headache um the engineers
on the other hand you know they're
they're you know hard at work on
some piece of the netflix infrastructure
and they want to to integrate you know
big data with with whatever they're you
know currently writing and so you know
they they want
a rich api layer that they can plug into
that's going to give them you know the
ability to to integrate big data with
whatever their application is so you can
think about you know the kinds of stuff
that netflix netflix would do with big
data um you know it feeds our algorithms
which is you know uh
something that we like to think is a
mighty part of you know our value
proposition um
it does things like fraud detection um
you know
tons of
applications use our data and we want to
make that as easy as possible for
engineers to be able to plug into
so you know as a data architecture team
you know we have to interface a lot with
um
the the the analysts we interface a lot
with the engineers um there's very few
of us that build this this platform and
so we want one you know base platform
that's going to you know meet
everybody's needs and expectations
um
so
one you know super unique thing about
the netflix architecture that you know
kind of stands apart from other
companies is we're not in a data center
netflix is pretty well known for running
their entire infrastructure on aws
and hadoop is no different and so before
i start talking about lipstick or any of
the tools that we've built on top of
hadoop
i think that you know it will put them
in a lot more context if i just talk a
little bit about what our architecture
is in general
and so one of the the chief denture
differentiating factors of the netflix
architecture versus a traditional data
center hadoop deployment is that we use
s3 as the source of truth for all of our
big data
and so you know while our clusters all
run
hdfs it's not used to store um any
source of truth information so
um you know think about you know you
write a hive or pig job and it compiles
into five map-reduced jobs they're gonna
persist intermediate results on hdfs
um but you know the the source and the
sync for those jobs is always going to
be s3
um and so you know that's that's pretty
great for us um in that it decouples our
storage from our processing um resources
so you know you can think of s3 as
essentially this giant infinite hard
drive in the cloud that's you know super
reliable um we don't have to worry about
any kind of single point of failure with
hdfs
name node
anything like that um
on the downside you know it decouples
our processing from our storage so
there's no such thing as locality
anymore um and so you know every time we
go out and and you know talk about our
architecture we we always get the
question of um you know how how can this
even be usable um seems you know that
locality is such an important part of um
hadoop in general that um you know
without hdfs and and with s3 it's just
not going to work well and so from all
of our benchmarking on
a production kind of workload you know
with these long-running scripts that
source from s3 and then put intermediate
results in hdfs and sync to s3
you know what we found is that we're
hitting you know maybe a 10
um penalty for for
doing that
um but you know it's not it's not
significant enough that that we feel
that outweighs the benefits of running
on s3 and so kind of some stats about
the kind of data that we're um sourcing
in we get we get um basically two
different sources um the vast majority
of the data is coming um is logging
event data through a log collection
pipeline we use um
something called hanu for that which is
a
deeply deeply customized version of
chakwa which is in the open source um
chakwa stands for turtle i think so does
hanu and we're looking at re-open
sourcing it
as some other word for turtle that i
can't think of right now but um
that that's the majority of our data
it's event fact based data
to add context to that data um we want
to dig into our stateful data stores to
um you know figure out
say an event is that customer 5 streamed
movie or downloadable asset 3 you know
at a certain time at a certain bit rate
right
that's kind of boring really what we
want to know is some information about
our downloadable asset 3 and our
customer 5.
and that information is all in our
stateful data stores which is primarily
cassandra at netflix
so we have another data acquisition
pipeline which is is smaller but
in certain ways a little trickier
out of cassandra basically we consume
incrementally data from cassandra as
it's created um we've built an app for
that called egg at this which if you
can figure out how to spell that and
google for it um there's some
blog entries about that that talk a
little bit more about how it works
but all in all you know it's mostly
events that we're consuming we get
around 100 billion events a day which is
you know pretty fun scale to play with
um
and you know we usually persist that raw
data for around 90 days
and so all told it's you know a
few petabytes of data that we've got on
s3 available to query
on our hadoop clusters at any given time
so
you know on top of that we're we're
running a bunch of hadoop clusters um on
sorry
all right so on on top of s3 we're
running multiple hadoop clusters which
is a benefit of being decoupled from um
our our storage layer you know we can
run multiple hadoop clusters against the
same you know
storage set
um and so you might think you know part
of the promise of of um hadoop is that
it should have good enough process
scheduling that you shouldn't have to do
that right
you should just be able to run a giant
hadoop cluster and
you know everything is decoupled and
isolated enough that everything is going
to perform
um you know unfortunately you know we
found that isn't the case there there is
a benefit to being able to run um
our production jobs in a separate
cluster of our wild west cluster that we
call the the query cluster
um and so kind of the the separation
there between our two main clusters is
we've got this batch workflow that runs
every night
we know the characteristics of it we
know you know what's scheduled in there
and we can kind of predict demand so um
we schedule our you know important sla
jobs on that cluster we have a a query
cluster that anybody can submit jobs to
at any time there's really no rules to
what they can do and so you know we want
to keep you know that kind of isolation
of do whatever you want from you know do
what needs to be done um and so we we
have two long-running clusters ones
that's for whatever you want one that's
for production
and
part of of um you know what we've been
able to do by being so decoupled is um
we steal excess capacity from
engineering at night when people are
asleep and not streaming movies and so
we stand up
some bonus clusters at night that we
transition
workflow traffic onto when they're up
and shut them down at like six in the
morning when we need capacity back so
you know multiple hadoop clusters
running is pretty elastic because of
those bonus clusters when we're stealing
siphoning capacity from the rest of our
engineering resources
um but you know all told it's it's a
little over 2000 instances running at
any given time and it can expand you
know i think it's it's elastic by around
800 nodes right now
but
you know having multiple hadoop clusters
you can think becomes pretty confusing
for users having to provision them for
three hours at night just to run some
production workflow on top of and then
shut them down
it creates a pretty complex
backend infrastructure
and you know that's fine as long as the
complexity is buying us um an
appropriate gain but definitely as a
team one of the things that we want to
do is you know one make that as
automated as possible for us but two
shield our end users from that kind of
complexity right so ideally
to an end user there should just be a
interface that you can submit a
mapreduce job to
and and it's going to give you results
back so you shouldn't have to know that
there's a production and a query cluster
you should definitely not have to know
that um 25 minutes ago we spun up a
bonus cluster from from um
uh you know excess engineering capacity
so we built this restful interface on
top of you know this you know multiple
hadoop cluster environment
um and we open sourced it uh at hadoop
summit what was it in in june um
so not very long ago but um you can
check out that project we call it genie
we call it genie because it grants three
wishes as long as those wishes are
running a hadoop job a hive job or a pig
job
um
but it's a github.com netflix
genie um and you know i know that the
author of genie would love some
contributions so if you're interested in
that um come and talk to me so the
question is that when you say clusters
are these like
permanently running clusters or like emr
uh
so
the question is um
are they permanently running clusters
are they transient um emr workflows and
the answer is they're kind of both
we do run the emr distribution of hadoop
but we don't run them as
traditional emr workflows we treat them
as semi semi-permanent clusters right so
they're transient in the in the sense
that
if if the query cluster or the
production cluster were to go down which
they sometimes do
um we
don't see it as a big deal you know we
just spin up a new one um but we don't
want those clusters to go down you know
there are a lot of instances they're
running long-running jobs um
we certainly don't want to spin up a new
hadoop cluster for every workflow that
we want to run through our system it
takes too long to spin up the instances
you know you're paying for partial
instance hours you know there's a lot of
reasons not to do it so um they are emr
um clusters but we we run so many jobs
per day which i'll talk about in a
little bit here but um we run so many
jobs per day that they're pretty much
always peaked at capacity and we just
keep them up so
so on top of
our emr clusters we've built you know
genie
and two other services so that a lot of
the three of those i like to call our
primitive services um
that you know we're building the rest of
our applications and architecture on top
of so you know obviously being able to
run your jobs is very important um we
also see you know is equally important
the ability to discover um all of your
data across the organization so we have
a metadata store named franklin that
basically abstracts you know all of our
other sources of truth for for metadata
into a homogeneous api to get to that
data
and we have something that we call the
event service which basically manages
orchestration of everything that's gone
on in the architecture so it's kind of a
history journal of um
jobs and events and important things
that have happened across the
architecture so it's actually a pretty
simple api that we don't really govern
um
a lot of the
the
use of but you know basically it's it's
the idea behind it is to record you know
what's going on so you can orchestrate
you know when to kick off your next
thing
um
so
you know the the scale of this is that
we run thousands of jobs a day i'm
honestly not sure the the exact number
um but at any given time our
architecture is managing around 100
map-reduced jobs that are running
and so you can kind of you know
do the math in your head of what the
scale of that is it's big actually you
probably can't do it in your head
because i can't but um
it's a lot of jobs that we're running
every day
um
on top of those three primitive services
we've built a variety of other tools and
so this is the space where lipstick fits
in
which is our you know workflow
monitoring visualization development
tool
um
in addition to that we have um ignite
which is kind of an av analytics
tool
um spock for data auditing
uh
forklift for data movement you know
inspired by korean from twitter
we thought forklift i don't know
looper for for kind of back loading jobs
so a use case that we um saw around
netflix quite a bit is that people
wanted to run um you know the same job
50 times for different date ranges to
fill tables in and so we just kind of
created a api for that
and sting which is kind of our
ad hoc visualization tool that takes
hadoop jobs pins them into memory and
allows you to do really fast olap style
aggregations against it so
um you know one the the important thing
about you know everything in this
architecture is that it's you know
highly decoupled um every tool is good
at one thing and it's not um you know
coupled to any of the other tools so you
know very um
uh decouple architecture also you know
we we follow um that kind of design
principle when we're when we're building
the tools themselves so typically
they're a restful api
with a decoupled javascript front end
sitting on top of them and and you'll
see you know that's how
lipstick is developed is you know
decoupled as possible
and it's how all of these tools are
developed in in general and that
pattern's worked really well for us um
you know a lot of our tools have a
javascript front end but um
you know a lot of times we
you know like to say it's just a
reference gui right like if somebody
else wanted to create a new um
graphing tool on top of steering you
know staying at its core is a api for
doing fast and memory
aggregation it's not a
visualization tool at heart right so
all of that is as decoupled as we can
make it
um so you know this is something that i
anticipate questions about but um you
know lipstick um for pig is um
you know what what i really want to talk
about today
but um you know we also use hive in our
architecture so you know a lot of pig a
lot of hive
people are free to do etl and their data
develop in whatever language they see
most fit to do it in
um typically you know our guidance to
them and what we see people doing is um
you know any kind of like one-off ad-hoc
query is going to be in hive like it's
really easy to think in sql um
especially if you're an analyst and
you've been writing sql for 20 years
it's just what you want to write and
naturally you know even me as an
engineer who doesn't love sql if i have
a question of the data
that i'm going to ask one time usually i
just write a sql query and it's really
easy right so um you know that that's a
sweet spot that we see for hive also you
know uh
lightweight aggregations that we do
hourly or daily um are easy to express
and they're efficient and high then you
know with some of that some of that
happens um
with pig we use it to express our
complex data flows in etl um so you know
i see pig as being good at a couple
things one it's a little more
declarative it's procedural
um it's it's generating a dag right
whereas um sql is is more functional
it's hard to um create multiple
forks in a data flow you can't really um
define what is actually logically
happening you're you're you're
totally coupled to a compiler to figure
out you know how your job is going to be
um structured and flow
um and so typically you know for for big
complicated workflows um people are
using pig because you know one it's a
simple language to write mapreduce jobs
in but two
it's a little
more
um
it gives the users a little more control
to define exactly how their job is going
to compile and how how things are going
to work so you know when we're running
these things
every day for the next three years you
know it's an algorithm to compute some
kind of recommendation
we want that to be efficient and well
tuned and gives us a chance to well tune
it
so for people who aren't familiar with
pig it's
a data flow language
so
it's simple to learn there's very few
reserved words um it's kind of
comparable to if if you've ever used um
like an explain tool in sql that
generates the logical plan about you
know what's going to happen in in your
sql language it's kind of like running
or writing a logical plan
for sql so you can think of it as being
slightly more complex
but giving you slightly more control
it's easy for us to extend and optimize
as a hadoop team
one one of the reasons for that is that
pig is
a completely client-side tool
so
we can actually run multiple versions of
pig against our clusters
we can you know
re recompile rebuild to try to fix bugs
and you know test that out without
you know
doing redeployments to our clusters and
having to muck with a lot of pain so
it's a little easier to develop on as a
infrastructure team and it's also you
know decent for our engineers to develop
on as
a etl development team and that they can
write
you know
macras and the pig language they can
write
all kinds of
udfs and java ruby python
javascript i don't know what else it
supports honestly we use
a lot of java udfs
or
less technical people that are writing
udfs typically do them in python
and that's worked well for us so far so
um this is just an example of what pig
looks like if you've never seen it um
it's it if if you can read the slide
from where you're sitting
you can see you know there's very few
reserved words i tried to bold them all
um
it's not super verbose so this is word
count it's what like
10 lines probably about as long as a sql
query would be and if if you write sql
you can recognize kind of a lot of the
same um constructs and and you know um
syntax as is writing a sql statement
so
um you know this is this is a kind of
reference um hello world script
but you know
that doesn't really um you know give a
justification for the reason for
investing in writing you know what
lipstick is which is a way to make
development easier you know if you're
seeing this you might think you know
development is is already easy why why
make it you know
even easier than this but the reality of
pig
is that
oh man that's dark
but um the reality of pig is that you
know it's it's not quite that simple
when you're trying to do complex things
and so um you know even though our
engineers aren't having to write java
mapreduce code
um you know they are having to express
some pretty complex logic and so what
the screen is supposed to show is kind
of a blurred out um
fragment of you know about 500 lines of
pig script that generates one of our
more complex workflows in netflix
and so
even if it was clear you wouldn't really
be able to see it but um
you would see a lot of syntax
highlighting in there tons of reserved
words um kind of a funky structure and
you can imagine you know when you have
500 lines of anything especially when
that 500 lines is trying to express a
dag um it's pretty impossible to keep
straight in your head how data is
flowing through operations um
and especially you know even if you're a
hadoop expert you know it's not super
intuitive how you know that much data
and transformation is compiling into
mapreduce which is something that's
important to understand if you're
looking at optimizing it
so
you know pig easy to express your data
flows
gives you the advantage of being able to
um
you know
logically group your your dag operations
um into into portions that don't
necessarily um
you know flow with the order of
execution of your data right so for
example
one of the patterns i like to tell
people at netflix is put all of your
load statements at the top of the script
put all of your store statements at the
bottom of the script but in reality you
know data might be loaded
for for one path through your dag
transformed and stored before you know
data is even loaded for you know the
other half right so um you know you're
logically grouping like operations
because it's easier to read and figure
out what the heck's going on with the
script when you have to maintain it but
um as far as being able to figure out
what the script is doing from a
mapreduce perspective it it makes it
even more difficult so um
uh you know it's it that that kind of
abstraction makes it easy to skip
operations uh overlook errors um
and
you know what we found is that
visualization of those scripts make it
really easy to um you know see all that
information that you're lacking and so
you know basically the history of this
is i was trying to to figure out how to
better support people because you know
we're an engineering team but we're also
you know part of the infrastructure
and so a common you know thing that our
analysts will bring to us is my pig
script is slow right and you know
that sucks for me to get that question
because you know especially if it's as
complicated as the one on the last slide
you know the first thing i have to
understand in order to try to optimize
their script is well what does it do
right and then i'm treated to like this
hour-long explanation of you know the
business context of what their script
does which is awesome you know
but um
you know it's still it's still hard to
keep straight and then i've got to read
their code i've got to figure it out
honestly if um you know our analysts
could support themselves and figure out
why their script was slow um they don't
have to explain what it's doing for an
hour they're happier i'm happier because
i get to write code instead of um
writing pig and so
we wrote lipstick you know it's kind of
just a tool to figure out you know what
what the heck their scripts do right and
so
the history of it is that that initially
it was a jyphon program that i could
just run against a pig script when it
was emailed to me and i would get kind
of a picture of how it compiles into
mapreduce
and that was really easy to write
surprisingly
um and
you know as i was going through it we
found that it was it was um great for us
as a team we could you know run run
these scripts through we would figure
out you know what's going on a lot of
the times um you know we would spot the
air in a couple of minutes and and go on
our merry way and it saved us a lot of
pain so we wanted to productionize this
as a tool that goes to you know
every script that ever runs in our
architecture archives it into this nice
graphical format
and saves all the metadata about the
execution into one place you know that
that people can look at and interact
with and use to write better better
scripts
develop faster
you know be be more productive folk
and so
you know this is kind of what the dags
that we generate through lipstick
look like
lipstick runs on apache pig 11 plus so
we we actually run a version of 11 that
we cherry pick um
patches from trunk um back into
i i'm pretty sure it runs on 12 as well
i haven't compiled it against trunk for
a while but if it doesn't work it's easy
to get to work and it is open source so
um
you know i don't i don't think it would
be that hard
um
at netflix at this point i tried to get
the numbers today we've run
well over 25 000 jobs um on lipstick
so it's pretty battle tested there's
there's a couple bugs with it like any
other open source project but
you know it's working well for us so
um be happy to have you guys give it a
try and
let me know if it's happily working for
you too
um
so
you know just walk through you know what
it does and and how it works a little
bit um the first interaction that any
user has with lipstick is just through
the standard out of
the the grunt shell or sorry the
standard air
it'll display a link that says navigate
to
some crazy link with a uuid to view the
progress of your script and it'll spam
that link to the user every time
pig heart beats progress so if you read
a lot of pics scripts you know it's like
one percent complete two percent
complete you know they'll get they'll
get the lipstick link every time um so
if they're to follow that link they'll
get a ui that looks like this
um
and so
there's some interesting pieces to this
that i can just walk through
over in the right there's a listing of
the overall job progress for your script
so it's basically you know what what we
know at a high level about what your job
when it started when it ended the status
of it
um the individual map reduced jobs that
it compiled down into and the progress
that those map-reduced jobs have um you
know made it through the script so this
job
compiled into five mapreduce jobs that
you can see over on the far right there
they're all complete
um
and so it says 100 map 100 reduce
over on the left is a representation of
the pig logical plan
um and so this is definitely the most
visually appealing portion of
the lipstick gui and so
zoom into this a little bit more
um
each light blue bounding box represents
a mapreduce job and inside of each
mapreduce job are
various logical operations that occur
right so a logical operation you can
think of um is having just about a
one-to-one correspondence with a line of
pig code
um and so if you write pig you know
you'll recognize from the top headers
here
um you know a lot of pig statement
operations so like for each group by
limit load store
are all logical operations and so you
know about those logical operators we'll
put any information that's pertinent to
those logical operations so if you're
writing a for each loop right you're
you're looping through every line of
input and doing something to it likely
you're changing the schema of the input
and so we'll um
we'll we'll put the schema like in the
graph below below the operation
if you're writing a join we'll put the
aliases that you're joining along with
the join keys and you know the join um
expressions that you're joining off of
if you're limiting we'll tell you how
many rows you're limiting if you're
grouping will tell you the group key
you know basically whatever is most
important to that
operation
um there's some color coding going on
here as well so anywhere that that
the pig gui shows or sorry the lipstick
gui shows orange
indicates that an operation is happening
on the reduced side so
these orange headers here are reduced
side operations
blue headers are map side operations so
one thing that's really easy to spot
with
within a lipstick graph is that if you
have all blue operations inside a light
blue bounding box it's a map only job
right
and one of the ways that you can use
lipstick to optimize your pig is you can
kind of fiddle with your logic in the
order of execution of things and you can
well well two things you can try to
reduce the number of map-reduced jobs
that are that are generated and you can
try to um you know force order of
execution into getting you more map-only
jobs
instead of jobs that have to to go
through a map in a reduced phase
um
if if this had been running in
production right now one of the other
things that you'd be seeing is light
blue bounding boxes would be flashing
either
the dark blue or the dark orange to
indicate that the job is either mapping
or reducing so um you know we demo this
a lot at like um
oss meetups at netflix and i have a
little station and it's you know running
these crazy complex graphs and there's
all these things flashing and you know
it makes people come over and talk to me
is kind of like the flame in the moth
but um
you know it is fun to watch and um you
know i've wasted countless hours you
know just watching people's crazy
scripts run in production views it's
kind of cool to see them start up and
you know things changing and numbers
incrementing
and speaking of numbers incrementing one
of the cool things that we do is um
in between any job well so for any store
any load and any intermediate output
that's generated we'll annotate the row
counts of
data that we see flowing through the
graph and so you know this this job
loaded 32 million records that joined it
with 99 million records which is fake
because it's a data set that i didn't
want to give away information about um
and it created 30 000 um roses output
right
so it's really easy to see that if the
job had currently been running
we would have been updating those
numbers live as we saw the data flowing
through
pig just using hadoop counters to get
the information about what it's done
so speaking of hadoop counters if you
were to click on any of the light blue
bounding boxes we would show you
high level information about the map
reduced job that ran and kind of the
goal here is to keep users in the
lipstick gui we don't want them
necessarily having to
link over to the job tracker to figure
out more information about their job
they should be able to debug it in one
place
um and so we'll show all the mapreduce
counters um that we can get as long as
well as some other information about the
job so like the
the pig aliases that were associated and
making the job run
and some other information about it when
it started when it ended what the
duration is that kind of stuff
so
um you know the the other benefit of
this and i'll talk a little bit about it
in the architecture side more but um you
know part of capturing those counters is
that we persist them right so everything
that lipstick shows you
is information that it's persisted into
a rds store somewhere so
you know even after that job has been
archived off the job tracker it's really
easy to still go and call up your
lipstick graph and see what it did
so
um
i guess high level view of lipstick i
should ask if there's you know any
questions or anything that you'd like me
to concentrate on for the rest of the
talk
um
or not
so
and talk a little bit about how it
facilitates
development running and operations
and you know really really
at its heart i wanted lipstick to be a
development tool
one of the common complaints around
netflix at least is that for any kind of
mapreduce development
iteration is really slow and so you know
part of that is is
users need to be trained to execute jobs
in local mode and part of that is just
that iteration is slow
um and so you know a solution to that is
to try to reduce iteration as much as
possible right like i i shouldn't have
to um run my my pig script 50 times
before i deploy it in production to
debug it right and so being able to um
visualize the workflows and kind of the
row counts on top of the the gui really
is intended to to make you know
iteration faster and so we do do a
couple of um additional things to
facilitate that so
um
probably one of the coolest things i
have a screenshot of it um later on in
the deck but
um we we sample all the intermediate
outputs between mapreduce jobs and so
that's something that in vanilla pig
isn't
possible to do
if if you suspect that you know in
between jobs you're getting bogus output
really you have to rerun your job and
you know create a new store command to
store out sample data
and you know wait wait for that to
execute again so um you know part of
what pig does or sorry lipstick does is
when it sees a job end it'll go and kind
of sample
about 10 rows of output from
the sample data set and present it in
the gui to the user um to look at right
and so we found that that really reduces
the number of iterations that need to
occur to
develop a script
just because you know if you can look at
data several places along your workflow
it's really easy to figure out you know
where the heck something went wrong
rather than you know it kind of being a
needle in a haystack trying to track
down what's going on
um
some other common problems that we see
um are omitted like hanging operators i
have an example of this in a minute but
um you know typically in pig you know
one of the things that you're trying to
do is um
filter early and often or do do um data
transforms um
uh
very early in your script right and so
you're writing all of these aliases like
expressing um a data flow like load your
data do this to it do this to it do this
to it
and it's really easy to lose track of
one of those operations right so i have
a b c and d this should flow in a linear
kind of workflow
and i accidentally connect a to b to d
and i forget about c
um
if if you can't visualize your workflow
there's a possibility that you'll just
never figure that out i mean it's not
obvious at all um and so pig or sorry
lipstick points that out for you um in a
pretty obvious manner that i'll show in
just a little bit um also you know a lot
of what you're doing um a sweet spot for
pig is is you know one of the things
that
um
the the trainers like to say is that a
pig can eat anything right and so um a
pig can can eat bad data a pig can also
eat unstructured data um and so a lot of
what you're doing is is typing things
and and hoping that it's that it's
correct right and so um
lipstick helps point out any kind of
data type issues that that you see in
your graph just through displaying
schema at every operation um
uh and making that kind of front and
center to the user so that when a data
type um does go bonkers a lot of times
it's a big bug sometimes it's a um
some weird syntax problem that isn't
obvious when you're developing um it it
makes it pretty obvious you know where
you need to go and look to debug that
um
so for job monitoring one of the the
biggest pains in the ask for me is that
you know pig executes and it'll run say
a typical pick script runs eight
map-reduced jobs right um if i want to
figure out you know what what the heck
that that
workflow looks like i have to kind of go
and look at the job tracker eight eight
different times and you know every
output of the job tracker is just this
boring black and white table and it all
looks the same
i can't really easily infer an ordering
to any of the executions of the jobs and
so if i can monitor my job running in
one place without
having to click around a lot
it makes it really easy for me to keep
that straight in my head
when i see that mapreduce 5
is 90 complete i can also see that
there's like two more jobs that are
going to execute after that they're
probably going to execute in parallel
and i can kind of think in my head how
long that's going to run for
whereas if i don't have that graphical
information
really i don't know
how far my script is along and i'm just
kind of guessing so
you know that allows you to spot
optimization opportunities at run time
as well if you're monitoring your job in
one place so you're seeing all those
input counters like through your joins
and things um and one of the the easiest
things you can do to optimize a
mapreduce job is to change your um
reduce side joins to be map side joins
right but you can only do that
if one of your relations is small enough
that you can you know pin it into memory
on all your nodes to join it
and so you know being able to see your
counters that are going into these joint
jobs you know you can see like oh you
know this side only has a thousand rows
at the point where i join it i can
probably make that a map side joint um
so it makes it really obvious um when
you can optimize like that um it also
allows you to see data skew pretty
obviously so um you know one of the
things that we'll see is that you know a
job will spin up a thousand reducers
nine thousand nine hundred not and nine
of them will they're sorry 999 of them
will um finish in like 10 seconds and
the other one will run for like 10 hours
right and so
using a lipstick gui you just click on
the job it'll say 99 complete you've got
this one reducer that's been running
forever
you can see you know that it's consumed
like a terabyte of data down the one
reducer and it's sorting it or something
silly
so um makes that pretty obvious um it
also makes it obvious you know when
things are running long one of the cool
things about pig is that at every reduce
operation pretty much you can
control the level of parallelism and so
you can kind of see how you could adjust
that to tweak things to run a little bit
faster and more efficient
you can also
kind of look at you know how things are
running so that you can tweak your logic
to um
compile the dag in a different way so
that things can execute concurrently and
you're not blocking workflow at
different
layers of your jobs
now for support which is um where i get
called in a lot you know i kind of
mentioned why i wrote it right um
rather than getting the email my job is
slow or um getting like five lines of a
stack trace you know
now we've kind of trained our users to
just mail a lipstick link to us and so
that gives us everything we need to know
it gives us the picture of the job which
is the first thing that i want to look
at
my hope is that i can solve their
problem just looking at the gui
but you know certainly you know it
contains all the information to all of
the logs and and everything that i need
to click around and get to right so from
uh infrastructure kind of support
perspective um having your users be able
to to mail you a lipstick link instead
of you know
seven links to different um
jobs in the job tracker is definitely
beneficial it makes them happier makes
us happier
and it gives us kind of a common
language that we can interface with
right like we can say well you can see
in the lipstick gui that um you know
you're casting this thing as a char
array and really it should be an ant and
that's why everything is cropping up
um
and so it really facilitates good
information um between uh infrastructure
and users and it also allows users to
support themselves so you know any big
data platform you know especially at the
the scale of netflix
you know it's kind of a mystery what the
heck is going on at any given time
and just netflix is one of those tools
that
facilitates operational transparency so
we always want our users to know
what their things are doing and why
and so a lot of the tools that we write
visualize that in in different ways so
we have you know another service called
sherlock and watson that um
we'll we'll give you kind of a graphical
picture of you know what what our
capacity is on the cluster and what's
going on at any given time um try to
compute you know the percentage of our
compute resources that any one user has
used over any kind of period right like
those kinds of things
i see lipstick is kind of fulfilling the
same class of tools but at a very much
lower level so the job level you can see
what your job is doing and why
and make smart decisions about it rather
than
not knowing what it's doing and not
making decisions at all so
um
a little bit about the architecture of
this i mentioned earlier that everything
we write as is d is is as decoupled as
possible
um and this is no different
there's three pieces to it and so
what lipstick is um is part of pig is
just kind of this drop-in jar that runs
alongside vanilla apache pig
and it implements an interface called
pig progress notification listener that
we use to
serialize our plans over to the server
and and report progress over to this
lipstick server so lipstick server the
little middle piece here um
is a lightweight grails app basically
all it's responsible for is taking
plans in progress persisting them to an
rds
and serving them to any kind of
front-end client that talks to the
interface
you know the most
well the piece of lipstick that people
interact with is
mostly the javascript client and so you
know that's our primary rest
client into this lipstick server
interface but you know there's other
tools that we could write against it as
well that do
cool things
so um you know decoupled into those
three pieces and i'll just talk a little
bit about you know what we're thinking
um at each step here so i mentioned a
second ago um the the
first piece of it the the console piece
is what we call it
implements this interface called pig
progress notification listener which
allows you to plug into various events
that occur in pig
so
the things that we listen for are new
statements to be registered so if you're
in the grunt shell and you type in a new
line of code or
you send a script through
pig it you know compiles each line
together and basically
creates a new a new dag for every line
of code that it sees and so um we're
actually capturing that dag at each step
um so that we can see how the how the
dag evolves
and we're able to kind of keep it in its
virgin state so it's this unoptimized um
version of your execution path through
pig
um
uh we we also listen for the event that
tells us that a script has actually been
launched so so compiled and launched
onto your hadoop cluster and what that
tells us is you know the the um
the
physical plan for how to run your your
jobs the mapreduce plans which i'll
explain what these are in a second but
um basically the mapreduce jobs that are
going to be executed
and an optimized version of that logical
workflow which is what pig is going to
actually do with what you wrote
so we also get you know notification of
completion and failure of any kind of
job that's executing um and heartbeat
events that tell us you know like hey
your pig script made some progress your
listener can wake up and um kind of go
and scrape information off of um off of
the job tracker to get you know those
counters that are updating in the gui in
real time
um so kind of the magic of lipstick is
that
it takes um these logical query plans
and it tries to figure out um how they
map into map reduce jobs
and honestly that's the only part of
this that's
really difficult to implement
because um
kind of the the optimization path for
pig is that it'll it'll take your pig
script it'll compile it into this
unoptimized
version of the workflow that needs to
run so it's just a list of or not not
always a dag of um
logical operations that are going to
execute
and you know it needs to compile that
into actual mapreduce code so as it does
that it'll take your logical query plan
which is your pig script it'll run a
bunch of optimization rules on top of it
so it'll kind of reorder things it'll
you know figure out um
what what kinds of filters it can push
to your litters and stores that that
kind of stuff right um and so from that
optimized logical plan it'll compile
that into a physical plan which are
kind of a lower level language that you
can use to express the actual mapreduce
that's going to happen and it takes
those physical plans which is another
dag that um is a little less readable to
the to the end user um and it it
compiles physical operations into
map-reduced jobs right and so at the
point of compiling physical operations
into map-reduce jobs you don't
necessarily have a link between um
physical operation and logical operation
and so a lot of the
craziness of lipstick is that it you
know follows those physical operators
and kind of makes an inference as to
what what logical operator is
responsible for those physical
operations and assigns them to map or
reduce side of the job
and
a job that executes them
so
um you know i talk about the console bit
a little bit more than the other pieces
because
that was
well the part that i've written but also
um you know the part that actually
touches pig
um the server bit is very very
lightweight we decided to implement it
in grails
kind of covered exactly what it does
earlier is basically you know there's
two clients into it one is the console
which is um you know writing to the
server it's posting um
plans and it's basically putting
progress um every time it it gets an
update from pig
and the javascript gui is is basically
the client that's performing all the get
operations right so um it's searching
it's searching um through
jobs to you know maybe by um
job name and by by username right to
figure out you know jobs that you're
interested in seeing and then it's
grabbing portions of the object that i
sent from the pig side to display to the
user
so
the javascript client is
the part of that i uh of lipstick that i
can probably talk about the least so i'm
not um great at writing um javascript
but um
basically you know the idea behind
the javascript client is that it's going
to take a picture of the dag which we
send from the server and svg format
and it's going to annotate that with
information about the heartbeat progress
from your job as it runs right so
you know we get
you know progress notifications that say
like you know we've read 30 million
records from this load operation and um
it's 30 complete right and so you know
it's the javascript client that knows
when to flash you know map produce
watches and you know annotate row counts
on top of the the um
the gui and so you know a lot of that is
is an event-based design right so it's
pulling the server it's getting this
heartbeat progress it's annotating the
picture um but you know all through the
rest of the interaction with the script
like you click on a mapreduce job um you
zoom in using that you switch in between
um plans it's just listening on user
events to um fire um things into our
back end that render
back to the view
so um
it is some pretty cool code as well um
you know take take a look at it
and have fun
basically when we were writing the
javascript client you know our key focus
is to keep people in the gui for
everything that they need to do commonly
um and also to make it as usable and
intuitive as as possible so um
kind of the secret around netflix is is
we rolled out lipstick for a while it
was running in production um we didn't
even tell anybody that we were going to
put it on top of pig we just kind of set
it there we let them discover that all
of a sudden they're getting these crazy
links that they can follow um and it
shows them like lipstick so um
you know we we tried to make it as
intuitive as possible because none of us
like to write documentation um and so we
actually didn't document how to interact
with the gui until we open sourced it
and at that point we kind of felt like
we had to
write a wiki and try to get a community
around it and make it easy to install
and use so
then we actually wrote the documentation
but the goal is that you know from an
end user's perspective we wouldn't
necessarily have to they should be able
to figure it out
and you know for the most part they
they've been able to so
um i'll just walk through a couple of
the ways you can solve problems with
lipstick um and you know one thing about
doing this in powerpoint is that it
doesn't look as cool as you know solving
the problem um in the gui like nothing's
flashing and changing
um so i apologize i actually think it's
cooler than the screenshots but
anyway so
your your first problem that you see a
lot is that your job you know you submit
it um it says it started but it doesn't
do anything right and so
you um look at the lipstick gui and you
know this is an actual job that really
did stall
um and it's reading this table called
vhs streaming session f and so that's um
basically a record of every um stream
that was ever started at netflix um
throughout throughout all of history
right and so you can kind of see it you
know it looks pretty legit it's a map
only job it's only got blue headers
right it's it's reading the data and
it's transforming it somehow right um
not super obvious why it's slow
and so you know i talked a little bit
earlier about optimized and unoptimized
versions of your query plan and dangling
operators and so this is an example of
that
what you're seeing right now is an
optimized version of your pig script
that's going to execute
and you can see up in the top right
there there's kind of a tab that you can
click on optimized and unoptimized so by
default we show you optimize view of
your your graph
but if you click over to unoptimized
you'll see this new operation shows up
and it's coded in red right and so what
red means is i don't know what the heck
to assign it to
right
um and the reason i don't know what the
heck to assign it to is because what
what was intended to happen with this
pig script is you were intended to load
your data um filter it for all of the
view streams that occurred since may 1st
and then do your transform on it but you
forgot about that filter right and what
happened is you ended up loading every
view that ever happened to netflix and
you're trying to transform it and um
your job hasn't even started yet because
it's trying to transfer you know
hundreds of megabytes of partition
information from
the the metadata server to figure out
even where the heck to go to read the
data
and so you know that that's a pretty
common error
it doesn't just happen on the load side
you know
you can you can omit operations all the
time and just get kind of bogus funky
results like you know we used to get
emails about um you know my udf isn't
executing right even though you know it
compiles right like i've tested it blah
blah blah right and so
um
you know before lipstick it was a tough
one for us too but you know now we know
to look and and half of the time we'll
go in and we'll be like you know
it's not executing because you didn't
tell it to right like you just forgot to
link it up in your dag
um
and so you know this it's been a big win
for us to be able to visualize that
um
you know another kind of problem that we
that we get all the time is that you
know i didn't get the data i expected to
get
and so an example of that is
kind of this right here so
this is the picture i was talking about
joining 100 million rows to 32 million
rows
and getting 30 000 is your output
right and so
i mean you know your data better than um
anybody else but typically when you're
joining millions of rows to millions of
rows um you would expect a bigger output
than 32 000 rows right and so um you
know you can search through the
execution history see what jobs are
executing this what they're doing um and
when they ran last for example so we've
got all that metadata um we could do
some pretty cool stuff with it
um and so you know it's one of the
things we plan to do or you know
convince one of you guys here tonight to
do
[Music]
exhibition uh and the same uh for job
commonalities or common data sets
how do you ensure the security of the
like two different users or two
different groups
they should not give anybody yes it is
yeah so the question is um how do we
ensure the security of our data sets and
graphs
and i'll say i love to work at netflix
um primarily because um we don't we
don't right
um and it is it's not a concern and so
part of the reason for that is that you
know ev every um
everybody at netflix
everybody has access to lipstick they
have access to our hadoop clusters they
can query any kind of data they want um
and and we trust them to to query only
what they should right um and so you
know there's two ways that we can allow
that one is we don't store any
personally identifiable information um
in in our
data warehouse
and two
is that every employee at netflix is
subject to insider trading rules right
so i can't trade the stock right now
because i'm out of a window because i
can see all the data right um and i
really love working in that environment
because um
everything is really transparent so
there's there's no secrets from
employees and it lets you make decisions
and contacts um and also as a platform
engineer i don't have to worry about
things that i don't want to have to
worry about which is you know probably
chief among them is authentication and
security so um
that's the the cheap answer to that one
um
also you know
we feel that we've left out hive for too
long
and so
we we kind of hacked together um
lipstick for hive the the other night
i'm not ready to commit it yet i might
submit it as a pull request so that
people can can use it but it's it's
still buggy we're not um we're not even
actively running it in production but it
but it works and it works um
uh better than i expected it to so we
don't know what to name it either um
we're bad at naming things um the the
the champion right now is is honey but
as my boss likes to say there's a
challenger champion model and you know
anybody that can come up with a better
name than honey which i hope you can um
can be the one to name it so
uh this is kind of what it looks like
it's a
a little less useful than um than pig
because we only have access to the plans
at
certain points
and and also you know it it
when i'm running sql you're you're bound
to the compiler right so it's a little
harder for me to tweak um how things are
going to execute and in what order but
you know certainly is is something
that's beneficial to know um
all the goodness of being able to
monitor and see row counts are still
there
if you used a graphical explain plan for
a sql database you know that it's
valuable and i mean this is essentially
that
so
if i zoom in it
in on it a little bit
you can see what it's doing
we've got all that map and reduced side
information there's a bug in the
screenshot where we're putting row
counts between each operator we don't
actually know that
we just know what it loaded and what
it's stored but
it works so
uh
you know to wrap up lipstick is part of
netflix oss you can clone it on github
play with it there's a quick start guide
and the wiki that should get you set up
in about five minutes to be able to run
jobs in local mode and see you know what
lipstick gives you
installing it on a cluster
is slightly more difficult i mean you
have to have a hadoop cluster to run
against for one thing
but it's not all that hard i know that
um
quite a few people already have have
been able to get it running and um
you know you have my email on the next
slide and we're happy to help you we
also have a google group that people can
submit questions to and i try to you
know answer that as quickly as i can so
um
you know we we happily welcome any
feedback
i've merged a few pull requests from
other people already
as long as you submit reasonable patches
i will try to get it into
the trunk of lipstick as quick as i can
and you know try to make it a better
tool i think there's a lot um that we
can do with it i think there's a lot
that can be done with it that i haven't
even thought of doing yet and so
certainly don't have a direction in mind
that i won't deviate from if you have a
cool idea so
help us out
look me up on linkedin or email me it's
just j magnussen at netflix.com
i am hiring
so
if you want to network and
be hired like suji said
we can certainly think about that
other teams that netflix are hiring too
so if if tools like lipstick and and um
and such aren't up your alley but you're
you're interested in more hadoop
infrastructure level work or even
something completely different
you can talk to me and i can definitely
get you in touch with you know who you
should be in touch with
so um thanks a lot
happy to answer any questions
oh one more thing so i have presents for
people
i ordered a thousand of these
and
i can't get rid of them yeah they're
chopsticks um
i thought about lying to you and saying
they're bacon flavored because then i
know you would take one
sadly i didn't think of it so they're
plain
unisex right
everybody needs chapstick please come
and take a chapstick um
i have hundreds of them so
that's that
any any questions about you know it
doesn't have to be about lipstick it can
be about
anything hadoop and netflix i'm happy to
answer it
so the the question is um what is the
difference between uzi and lipstick and
so you know uzi is a workflow tool and
so essentially you would um use it to
define a
chain of
pig hive and hadoop jobs that are going
to run in sequence right whereas
lipstick operates at the level of just
your job right and so they're um not
mutually exclusive um
really you know the the lipstick is
there to to monitor what your job is
doing uzi is there to execute um a chain
of jobs in sequence and to handle errors
and things
while doing that so um you know we we
have a scheduling tool at netflix that
we use um
called uc-4
which is yeah i saw a surprise face
um so that's our alternative right now
to uzi um there's there's um
benefits and and detriments to doing
that that i won't talk about um right
now but happy to talk about offline
and there are a couple of really cool
tools so like spotify has recently open
source something called luigi which is
an awesome workflow manager um so so is
usually pretty cool i mean it's it's
definitely a top contender you know
amongst people that are doing um
workflows in hadoop um amazon has an api
for doing it um there's eskaban from
linkedin so there's a lot of solutions
to the to the problem of workflow
management
yeah so there's a couple things that we
want to do with it so we're um
oh sorry uh can you the question is can
you do a dry run to just get a picture
of the graph without um
without executing it and so the way that
i do that right now is i just execute it
and then control c out of it really
quick right and so it won't actually
kick off the job right like it'll i'll
see the
little error message that says it sent
it over to lipstick and then i'll ctrl c
you know obviously that isn't where we
want to be
um
we're working with a company who who's
been looking at it called mortar data
that publishes some um
cool um
pig development tools right and so
they
are looking at
integrating it into something you know
they're just interested in it
they they recently open sourced a tool
called watchtower which is super cool
and that
basically pig has this thing called
illustrate that will show you a sample
of what your data should look like at
each step of the job and so one thing
that i really love to do is have that
explain mode that gives me the graph but
also incorporates what watchtower is
doing which is um
annotating like each line of code in
each operation with a sample of what the
output would look like
so um you know that's that's it's all
open source watchtower um
lipstick it's something that we'd like
to do once we get the time so
uh
oh sorry did you have another question
if there is a there are hot spots or
those optimizations where you're talking
about
changing the map reviews to map only
jobs so if you're on annotations will
they make any recommendations are only
like you know i
um so are you talking about like what
we'd like to do which is to um like kind
of show warnings or yeah
[Music]
so the question is basically um does it
does it do any kind of coaching or you
know telling you what what you can do to
make your script better um right now it
doesn't kind of uh the the way that i
think that
should should be implemented is that you
know we just have a rules engine that we
can plug in that examines the graph
um and you know figures out you know
what optimizations that could could be
made and reports them back to the to the
ui
um and so
uh definitely something that we plan to
do
um but it but it doesn't do it yet so
you know it's up to the user to look at
it right now and figure out what they
could do better um
a lot of times it isn't obvious you know
even even when you see it graphically
what you could do better and so that's
why we want to
you know just help people along
oh man
all right so
uh the the sample of the question is how
are we getting the sample data and it's
a it's a bit of a hack um
uh
on the the physical operators that
represent the load and the store um they
have linked to them the the function of
um
basically the the store right that it
used for intermediate outputs right um
and so we do a little introspection we
give ourselves access to the to the um
to the function that stores we we open
its reader we know the uri that the data
was stored out and we go and we sample
it so you know not something that we're
proud of but you know the end result
we're proud of and that's really all
that matters so
that's how we do that
um was there a question in the back
basically a lipstick graph inside of um
it's a it's an eclipse plug-in right
here uh okay so i haven't seen um a
jenkins plug-in that that does this um
you know there are a couple similar
tools so um
uh twitter has something called ambrose
that does a similar level of monitoring
um
i i can imagine something that you might
do in jenkins um
really you know that that's precipitated
by you running jenkins against um
if you're arguing that a graph is a
wonderful helpful thing maybe
start from them
yeah so um you know there's a
long history of
etl tools that are graphical development
tools um
really
there's no no code in um
lipstick that that necessarily makes
that easy you know i'm not starting from
them right i'm taking um the result of
a plan which is a dag and i'm just
visualizing it
we do have a tool that somebody wrote
for a hack day at netflix called piglets
which allows you to develop graphically
these plans um that develop from a tool
that that um
we call higg which is basically a
compiler for hive and it's a pig
and so you know we we had to have that
in order to um
you know understand objects and how to
glue them together um and so yeah you
can you can
draw graphically these pig scrubs but
the question is you know one
is it pig anymore right like you know
there's
netflix is i mean even open to debate
about this too we've got users that want
a graphical etl tool and we've got users
that you know threaten to murder me in
my sleep if i you know develop it for
somebody right
and so you know people some people
really want it you know because it's how
they think they're used to writing etl
graphically
some people really hate it because
you know they don't want to learn how to
use a graphical tool they want to edit
their scripts in bi
and i'll confess i'm that guy right but
you know i certainly see both sides and
i don't know the answer to doing it i
mean
there's
probably i would start a startup if i
was developing a graphical etl tool for
pigment
um
any more questions
um so there's various schedulers that
you can plug into hadoop that allow oh
sorry the the question is how how do we
just let everybody or yeah all of our
users run whatever scripts they want um
it's really easy to use all the
resources on that cluster um and to a
certain extent you know that's
absolutely true it's why we segregate
our production workflow from the wild
west kind of stuff
but
uh
you know hadoop is supposed to be good
at that in theory and so um you know one
of the things that we we use on that
query cluster is a preemptive
scheduler and so if if i have a job that
needs to be scheduled and you have your
job that's using the whole capacity of
the cluster
my job can actually go and kill some of
your tasks so that i can execute and get
my fair share right
and so that's that's how we get around
it you know other ways that we get
around it at netflix um
if a user has
um
a
specific need that they warn us about a
couple hours ahead of time we'll just
spin them up a personal cluster and they
can go to town
and you know that's that's partially an
advantage of running in the cloud and
that you can just elastically provision
you know nodes from amazon
but you know i think the way that you do
that in a data center is just a
fair share scheduler kind of um
model
so maybe maybe one last question
[Music]
we have a mix of all three um a lot of
our well
over 90 of our etl is written in pig
um
we we i'd say
99 of ad hoc analysis is done in hive
um and then we've got you know our
engineers who aren't you know working in
bi and you know aren't statistician but
they're
engineers like hardcore they'll um
implement things in java mapreduce
and so we really do we do get a mix um
every tool is good at you know a certain
thing and people use it for what it's
good for
[Applause]